[Music]
good morning NOC today is Friday May 4th
tomorrow is Saturday May 5th your 27th
birthday
[Music]
you
want to say happy birthday Hank remember
when I told you that the top-secret
project involves some kind of viral
marketing I was lying I don't even know
what viral marketing is happy birthday
happy birthday Hank
[Music]
I rolled out of it
with a my mouth
got his belly
it's against the law
Oh
but the give love
[Music]
well I'm on my way
hello and happy birthday today happy
birthday game in home in Wisconsin
[Music]
we're young
I didn't do the black area
[Music]
everyone knows I'm in love with the -
Allah beggar happy birthday from creepy
Carl and Logan and Brody and Ann happy
birthday hey we are a synthetic template
and
[Music]
grunts ah
time
[Music]
everybody's been swapping you
okay yeah I know does my face look shiny
look shiny
hey birthday greeting take 29
[Music]
happy birthday hey damn it
happy birthday hey happy birthday hey we
love you thank you hey happy birthday
Hank mmm happy birthday
[Applause]
[Music]